today i want to reiterate re-emphasize
and reassert this call
civilian populations including
journalists and non-combatants must be
protected
attacks against civilians or civilian
objects must stop and the human rights
and fundamental freedoms of all afghan
citizens especially women girls and
members of minority groups must be
respected
we also call on all parties to prevent
terrorism and we must all ensure
afghanistan cannot ever
ever again be a base for terrorism
we also call on the taliban to permit
humanitarian organizations
to continue their valuable work in
afghanistan
in addition to the ongoing violence the
afghan people are suffering acutely from
the effects of covet 19 and drought
these urgent humanitarian needs must
remain top of mind for all of us in the
coming hours days and weeks
and beyond
humanitarian personnel and agencies must
have safe unhindered access to provide
life-saving assistance to the increasing
numbers of afghans in need
we are deeply concerned that right now
aid is not flowing to people in crisis
according to the world food program more
than 500 tons of aid are currently
sitting at border crossings taken over
by taliban forces
these aid deliveries must remain must
resume immediately and the world food
program must have immediate and
sustained safe passage to deliver this
much needed assistance
finally and critically all afghan
nationals and international citizens who
wish to depart must be allowed to do so
safely
president biden has made clear that any
action that put u.s personnel or
omission at risk will be met with a
swift and strong military response
the united states promises to be
generous in resettling afghans in our
own country and i'm heartened by the
pledges we've seen from other nations to
do the same
we need to all do more and the time to
step up is now